Film Courage: When did you decide you were
going to begin your own studio?
Jay Silverman, Photographer and Filmmaker:
When I graduated from Brooks Institute, I
think 1975 believe it or not?
I was fortunate enough to occupy a rental
building that had a little teeny office and
from the very beginning of my career I saw
the advantages of having some kind of exclusive
place that I can go to each day rather than
work out of my house and that extended over
time and into me acquiring a studio.
And then it became really a great part of
the complexion of my career is to have the
tools available 24/7 versus waking up in the
morning, producing a movie and renting everything.
So I did what probably is not even possible
anymore but I started to acquire stuff and
save it and I did that through all of the
years that I’ve been in this business which
has been quite a substantial amount of years.
Film Courage: Like 37, you have on your [web]site?
Jay Silverman: I’ve been in the business
doing television and commercials for at least
20, but I’ve been in the field for 37 years.
Film Courage: So going back 37 years what
did you envision success to look like versus
what do you envision it to be now?
Because I know when someone starts a venture
they have all these grand ideas about how
life’s going to be and what it’s going
to be like every day to run a business but
then having been in the trenches, 7 days a
week.
Jay Silverman: Well, it’s a very interesting
question because as I reflect back on my career,
I’m one of the few guys that actually has
a left brain and a right brain, where I am
a businessman and I’m also a creative guy.
And that’s an unusual combination and ultimately
I knew from the very beginning (and this is
the same thing I tell my three daughters),
if you’re lucky enough to find a career
where you can do what you love, the money
and all those other things come later, but
they do come.
I started from scratch and little by little
I built a business and one thing leads to
another and then finally (probably at the
beginning of the 1980’s) I started doing
what I call hybrid filmmaking which means
I would not only do still photography, I’d
do live action and it became a category that’s
now taken for granted because everybody wants
sound bites and everybody wants beautiful
visuals and now you can theoretically do pulls
off of a Red camera or the camera you are
using right now [Canon 5d Mark II].
And they are usually 2K or 4K and you don’t
even need to bring in a still photographer,
so I was doing both.
Film Courage: What was the biggest surprise
for you in having run a business for over
37 years, you know?
The 80’s were a much different time [financially]
than it is now.
Social media wasn’t around.
Jay Silverman: The whole thing is about reinventing
yourself.
It’s funny, as I was driving into work in
the morning it became like almost an epiphany
in my own mind in that I’m not doing anything
like I was ten years ago.
So I basically had to reinvent myself and
as I’ve looked back in my career, that’s
all that I’ve done.
Throughout my whole career is to reinvent
myself.
You become a photographer (as what I was for
many years) and you all the sudden wake up
in the morning and go “My God I’ve been
working on this one client for four years.
Inevitably that’s great for the pocket book,
not much for the advancements of what I want
to be doing creatively.”
So you adapt.
And it’s crazy because I had one client
from ABC that told me “Why are you getting
that big studio in Hollywood.
Can you actually make a living with that big
studio?”
And I know this is total cliche but it’s
like the Kevin Costner statement If You Build
It, They Will Come…I lucked out because
at the time that I built that studio (which
was at the end of 1999 I built this studio)
I found myself in a very unique situation
that I didn’t even realize which is most
people were getting rid of their studios,
they were renting them.
I became a guy that actually had my own place.
And as crazy as this sounds, Roger Corman
was a little bit of that motivation and it
was also my desire to create a place where
that creativity could grow, where you could
sit outside and have a cigarette or lunch
and sit down next to a writer or sit down
next to a DP or really take a position of
collaborating and that was fun.
Film Courage: Did you have entrepreneurs in
your family?
Did you see them model this?
Jay Silverman: Not a single entrepreneur.
My dad was a sheet Metalist and my mom was
a PTA housewife.
I have two siblings and no…I just lucked
out and had a passion for what I did and I
was able to sit back and go “How can I take
that and actually make more of it?”
And just to finish your first question which
relates directly to the formation of setting
up a business and going after what you want,
I’m currently on my third film now.
And this film equates to being part of that
vision of working on meaningful projects.
In this particular case, this movie is a romantic
comedy.
It’s also a pretty strong statement about
edible food and inedible food, meaning fast
food and farm-to-table.